würd gerne mal den Migrationsforscher
Rüd kopmn zitieren der sagt unter den
Flüchtlingen die möglicherweise dann
auch demnächst nach Deutschland kommen
werden sich viele hamasanhänger befinden
und es wäre ein Leichtes für aktive
Kämpfer von Hamas und dem islamischen
dihad sich unter sie zu
mischen das kann passieren wie gehen wir
damit um darum wird es umso notwendiger
sein dann auch eine strengere
Überprüfung stattfinden zu lassen und
zwar nicht gegen die verfolgenten
Menschen sondern im Interesse der
verfolgten Menschen denn nichts wäre
schlimmer als wenn wir uns hier Schläfer
ins Land Brechten die dann den Terror
aus dem Land bei uns fortsetzen da ist
größte Wachsamkeit geboten und da sind
die Behörden das sind die schutzbehörden
das sind die verfassungsämter und
ähnliche mehr wirklich gefordert da ist
auch eine enge Zusammenarbeit mit Israel
erforderlich israel hatte ja mal den
besten geheim Dienst aller Völker da
wird man mit ihnen zusammenarbeiten
müssen um da zu sehen äh sind es Leute
die unsere Hilfe bedürfen oder sind das
Leute die unseren Staat kaputt machen
wollen das ist in der Theorie so in der
deutschen Wirklichkeit ist es
mittlerweile so dass sich ein Gefühl von
ich sag mal Kontrollverlust breit macht
sie sie nicken sehen sie auch so ja das
war ein Problem
auch bei der Flüchtling
well
2017m da waren die Menschen durchaus
bereit großes zu tun für die
echtbedrückten aber es war ein Stück
Kontrollverlust es war nicht mehr
gesteuert wenn einfach eine
Menschenmenge
über die Grenzen geht dann weiß ich
nicht mehr wer ist es und das glaube ich
ist notwendig zu wissen woher kommt
jemand wer ist jemand was beabsichtigt
er soweit man das feststellen kann diese
Kontrolle notfalls auch an deutschen
Grenzen wiederherzustellen halte ich für
notwendig und für richtig sie sie selber
haben mal gesagt Nächstenliebe kennt
dann eine Grenze wenn ich selber so
ohnmächtig bin dass ich diese nächsten
Liebe nicht mehr ausleben kann das ist
so ähnlich wie der Satz von von GA von
Gauk der gesagt hat
unsere Möglichkeiten sind endlich und
das muss man glaube ich begreifen
äh Solidarität und Nächstenliebe ist das
wichtigste Gebot der Bibel aber sie kann
auch missbraucht werden und dann muss
ich dagegen halten und muss schauen was
kann ich mir und was darf ich mir und
meinen Mitmenschen
zumuten von von Helmut Schmidt gibt es
viele Aussagen auch zu diesem Thema der
immer wieder auch drauf hingewiesen hat
und gesagt hat wir wir müssen da ehrlich
sein wir reden auch über verschiedene
Kultur Hintergründe wir reden über
andere Religionen wir müssen aufpassen
dass wir irgendwann den Zusammenhalt der
Gesellschaft nicht gefährden bzw eine
Gesellschaft nicht überfordern sehen sie
auch so ja das sich mal mit dem darüber
ausgetauscht ich weiß dass sie sich gut
kannten jedes Mal wenn ich früher in
Hamburg war solange er lebte habe ich
ihn besucht und wenige Wochen vor seinem
Tod schreibt er mir einen Brief lieber
Theo Weigel schreibe Ihnen ohne Anlass
will ihnen nur meine Anhänglichkeit
unter weisstellen freue mich in ihnen
einen Freund in Bayern zu haben so also
das
ist ein Brief mehr Liebe geht nicht er
mich sehr sehr bewegt und es war
interessant mit ihm sich auszutauschen
über Gott und die Welt zu reden
äh merkwürdig war immer die ersten 10
Minuten braucht er um über hemokol zu
schimpfen und dann fragte er mich wer
hat Bayern am weitesten gebracht war das
mochel oder war es Franz Josef Strau und
ich habe ihm gesagt beide waren wichtig
aber es gibt auch noch ein paar andere
aber zurück zu Helmut Schmidt korrekte
Antwort lautet natürlich Markus Söder
ist ja das war jetzt eine Frage auf die
ich nicht vorbereitet bin so aber aber
zurück zu ihm er hat sich um die Frage
Weltreligionen ja natürlich immer sehr
gekümmert zusammen mit Hans Küng und das
bräuchten wir vielleicht wieder mehr uns
zu kümmern wo sind die Gemeinsamkeiten
wo sind die trennenden Dinge eugin biser
Stiftung hat das in den letzten Jahren
versucht das was Hans Küng da begonnen
hat in Tübingen müsste unbedingt
fortgesetzt werden um auch mit dem Islam
eine kritische produktive
Auseinandersetzung durchzuführen was ist
gemeinsam und was ist etwas was wir auf
gar keinen Fall akzeptieren können
nämlich Islamismus als ja gewalttätige
Form des Umsturzes unserer
Gesellschaftsordnung was hat was hat
Helmut Schmidt da in seinem ganzen
Pragmatismus gesehen was andere offenbar
nicht gesehen haben ja er hatte da auch
nicht immer ganz recht ETW die eine oder
andere Meinung von ihm würde er
vielleicht heute so nicht mehr so nicht
mehr er hat alles sehr relativiert g
aber das tolle an ihm war dass er als
Staatsmann sich mit den Weltreligionen
beschäftigt hat und da frage ich mich
welcher Politiker von heute beschäftigt
sich noch mit theologischen Fragen mit
wirklich philosophischen Fragen das hat
er versucht Franz Josef Strau konnte das
Helmut Kohl war ein Mann der sehr stark
in der Geschichte immer grübelte ein
bisschen fehlen mir heute die Typen die
also neben der Pragmatik auch in der
Programmatik ja Tiefenwirkung hatten
oder auch in der Polemik Franz Josef
Strau war sicher ein Mann dem Polemik
nicht fern warn sagen aber es war
Polemik mit Tiefgang oder herbert Wehner
wie habe ich mich über den geärgert wenn
er uns niedergemacht hat im Parlament
aber es war eine Polemik ja mit Ziel und
auch mit Tiefgang über die man auch mit
ihm mal gelegentlich diskutieren konnte
und das ist der Unterschied aber ich
will jetzt nicht die guten alten Zeiten
beschwören es war nicht alles gut aber
jedenfalls waren die typpen die ich
damals kennengelernt habe interessant
nur nur weil sie das gerade ansprechen
Herbert wienner und sagen das hat das
hat mich echt geärgert was war der
schlimmste Satz von wenner über
Sie also das weiß ich nicht mehr aber er
hat mich in meiner ersten bundestagsrede
hat er mich stark genervt ich habe
nämlich da gemeint wenn ich ein ein Satz
von Bert Brecht zitiere über den Umgang
mit Geld et war dass das
eigentlich für jemand der aus dem
bayerischen Schwaben kommt akzeptabel
sei und darauf sein Zwischenruf können
Sie auch noch jemand andere
zitieren also ich habe gesagt kann ich
selbverständlich aber Brecht müsste doch
für Sie her wenner äh genehm sein also
ja ich habe ihn ganz am Schluss seines
Lebens trfen wir uns als er die
Ehrendoktor würde einer israelischen
Fakultät bekam da war ich zugegen und
fragte ihn her wenner darf ich sie mal
besuchen der schaute mich an und sagte
kommen Sie vorbei es ist dann leider
nicht mehr dazu gekommen mhm ins Hier
und Jetzt ähm Weigel wie wie schauen Sie
auf dieses europäische Projekt wie
schauen Sie auf die Tatsache dass wir
wir haben ja vorhin so ein bisschen
gemeinsam diesen Traum geträumt es ist
89 es ist 90 es ist irgendwann
wiederereinigung und und dann und dann
gehen wir in sehr glückliche Jahre und
sehr glückliche Jahrzehnte in jedem Fall
aus deutscher Sicht und plötzlich
erlebst du dass rund um uns herum die
Ränder immer stärker werden plötzlich
merken wir dass Deutschland in gewisser
Weise immer noch so eine Art Ausnahme
ist und immer mehr wird plötzlich merken
wir was in den USA passiert diese sehr
extrem starke Polarisierung wir merken
es plötzlich auch im eigenen Land wir
sehen den Aufstieg der AFD wir sehen in
Bayern einen Wirtschaftsminister Hubert
eiwanger der damit erfolgreich ist sag
gegen die da oben zu wettern obwohl er
teil von denen da oben ist wie geht's
ihnen wenn sie da drauf schauen ja die
Welt hat sich schon verändert aber es
ist nicht alles schlecht mir geht nicht
schlecht will aber sie hat sich
verändert Europa ist auch heute noch ja
eine Insel der relativ glücklichen und
ich möchte nicht mit dem Europa tauschen
das wir vor 35 Jahren
hatten ich habe mal mit Hans Magnus
Enzensberger darüber debattiert der
schrieb ein kleines Büchlein von 35
Seiten davon waren 33 negativ über alles
was schief läuft in Europa und zwei
Seiten da beschrieb er wie schlimm seine
Kindheit war und wie glücklich das ist
was sich dann in Europa an Freizügigkeit
und so weiter ergeben hat und ich habe
gesagt lieber großer Meister wä es nicht
gut gewesen wenn sie von den 35 Seiten
vielleicht die Hälfte über die positiven
Dinge Europas gesprochen hätten und
geschrieben hätten so und drum bin ich
immer ein bisschen dagegen nur das
Negative zu sehen nur die Probleme es
gibt auch viele positive Dinge und
Europa ist auch heute noch das teulste
Friedensprojekt es hat viele Defizite
aber trotzdem für uns und gerade für
Deutsch Land ein riesen Gewinn und ohne
Europa hätte es auch die
Wiedervereinigung nicht gegeben aber was
sie natürlich darstellen das ist richtig
die eine oder andere Entwicklung
vielleicht entwickelt sich Polen jetzt
wieder anders also in den nächsten
letzten Jahren
wenn ich Orban sehe streuben sich mir
die nicht mehr vorhandenen Nacken Haare
und natürlich auch mancher Rechtskurs
nichtw wenn ich jetzt an die Slowakei
und ähnliches mehr denke trotzdem wir
haben es bisher immer geschafft die auch
zu integrieren und in verschiedenen
Ländern die ich sehr liebe wie
Niederlande und Finnland das waren immer
meine besten Freunde die Finanzminister
die standen immer auf meiner Seite g da
hat es auch immer wieder Parteien
gegeben die alles andere als sympathisch
waren und trotzdem haben es die Länder
geschafft am europäischen Kursen
festzuhalten auch Frankreich hat es
geschafft und wir werden es auch
schaffen und dann muss man nur
vielleicht auf etwas
rekurrieren Politik darf nicht in Hass
und Wut
erstarren und das findet im Moment in
Deutschland leider auch statt es wird
sehr destruktiv und da bin ich dran
erinnert vor 100 Jahren hat einer der
bedeutendsten Theologen Karl Bart
zwischen den Zeiten geschrieben zwischen
den
Zeiten weiß man nicht was kommen soll
man weiß nicht was kommt aber zwischen
den Zeiten ist man wahnsinnig stark im
Negativen kritisiert alles Bestehende
und macht es fertigm und das führt dann
kann zum Chaos führen genau und was der
vor 100 Jahren geschrieben hat
1922 ist heute wieder lebendig so und da
denke ich an die schlimme politische
Theorie von Karl Schmidt der war einer
der Chefideologen im juristischen
Bereich auch im Nazi Deutschland später
hat er sich davon etwas distanziert wird
aber heute noch zu meinem großen
Erstaunen von vielen verehrt wie ein
ganz großer mhm und dessen Theorie
bestand darin dass politische als
freundfeindverhältnis zu sehen und das
ist eine Katastrophe die führt immer
wieder zu solchen auswächsen Politik
bedeutet etwas anderes politik bedeutet
Streit
Auseinandersetzung und auch harte
Attacke aber Politik muss auch bedeuten
in wesentlichen Dingen einen Dialog zu
führen Kompromisse zu schließen und
wieder zusammenzukommen und eigentlich
ist uns das seit 1949 in Deutschland
ganz gut
gelungen bei der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft bei der Errichtung der
Bundeswehr bei der Bekämpfung des
Terrorismus oder dann später bei der
Wiedervereinigung und bei der
europäischen Einigung bei all den in
brauchte ich eine zwei Drittel Mehrheit
und hatte einen verantwortungsvollen
schwierigen aber
verantwortungsvollen Partner bei der SPD
nämlich Hans Jochen Vogel und auch
später wenn ich daran
denke Agenda 2010 etwas Notwendiges und
richtiges was Schröder durchgesetzt hat
er konnte es nur Beil die CDU CSU im
Bundesrat und in den Ländern mitgemacht
und an eines Projekt unterstützt hat und
drum jetzt komme ich noch gleich auf den
nächsten Punkt hielte ich es für
notwendig große Projekte die nur
gemeinschaftlich gestaltet und bewältigt
werden können miteinander zu machen
nicht in einer großen Koalition aber in
einer großen Zusammenarbeit zwischen
Regierung und Opposition wie es das auch
in der Vergangenheit immer wieder
gegeben hat und das ist die
Flüchtlingsproblematik das ist die
Migration das ist die Wirtschafts und
Finanzpolitik Verteidigungspolitik es
kommt gleich wenn wir am Schluss im
Moment aller Länder im Westen stehen
dann ist es doch Alarm hoch 2 darüber
nachzudenken wie kommen wir wieder zu
Wachstum und wie können wir mit mehr
Wachstum das Notwendige tun auch
konsolidieren und so weiter oder dann
komme ich zur Verteidigung vor 70 Jahren
ist die europäische
Verteidigungsgemeinschaft gescheitert
1952 wurde sie etabliert und da erinnere
ich mich an die großen Reden von Franz
Josef Straus der damit die Bayernpartei
im Grunde besiegt hat Bayernpartei heute
so ähnlich wie Freie Wähler und eiwanger
und Strauß hat die CSU dazu gebracht
nicht bayerischer zu sein als die
Bayernpartei bayerisch zu sein aber auch
Deutsch und europäisch und hat die
europäische Idee an die Spitze einer
modernen Partei gerichtet und heute
bräuchten wir wieder eine europäische
Verteidigungsgemeinschaft 2 nach 70
Jahren um wenigstens die
Rüstungsvorhaben und ähnliches
miteinander zu gestalten es ist doch
absurd wenn Amerika über einheitliche
Waffen verfügt und wie in Europa über 10
15 verschiedene äh verschiedene Projekte
also eine europäische Armee es muss
nicht eine europäische Armee sein ich
wäre schon zufrieden wenn einige
europäische Spezialtruppen gemeinsch
enehen könnten und wenn der nächste
Panzer der nächste Fighter die nächsten
Projekte gemeinschaftlich gemacht werden
zwischen Deutschland Frankreich und
Spanien und und Italien das wäre
notwendig und das anzugehen wäre ein
wahnsinniger
Synergieeffekt und mit solchen Projekten
könnte man auch den Menschen sagen wir
tun das notwendige über Parteigrenzen
hinweg und das wäre die beste Methode um
die AFD wieder zu eliminieren noch mal
Franzose Strau weil sie den so häufig
Zitieren von dem stammt ja auchagen die
Idee rechts von der CSU ist kein Platz
mehr da gibt es niemand mehr jetzt haben
sie in Bayern rechts von der csuen sie
noch mal 15%. ich korrigiere sie ungern
aber er hat gesagt rechts von uns darf
keine demokratisch legitime Partei
entstehen ja ist richtig auch zu seiner
Zeit kam die NPD mal in den Bayerischen
Landtag war und auch zu seiner Zeit ist
Schönhuber entstanden et war der mit ihm
früher mal befreundet war und dann knapp
ganz knapp an der 5% Kusel in Bayern
scheiterte und bei Kommunalwahlen und
Europawahlen Erfolg hatte bis zu 20% und
in mehreren Landtagen nicht zuletzt
Baden-Württemberg vertreten war
also das Ziel ging da oder geht dahin
keine keine demokratisch leg Partei
entstehen zu sind die Freien Wähler
keine demokratisch die Freien Wähler die
setz sich nicht gleich mit der AFD nein
das sind sie ganz sicher nicht sie sind
aber sie sind rechts von der CSU sie
sind rechts von der CSU und ich sage
noch mal die Bayern Partei hat es 10
Jahre gegeben sie müssen sie mal
vorstellen
1946 hat die CSU 22% geholt 4er Jahre
später nachdem die Bayernpartei und der
BHE entstanden war war sinkt die CSU auf
27,3% fast die
Hälfte und dann
1949 war die erste Bundestagswahl und da
holt die Bayernpartei 11 Direktmandate
in Oberbayern und Niederbayern und kommt
mit 17 oder 19 Mandaten ins in den
Deutschen Bundestag und Adenauer wollte
die mit in die Regierung holen um seine
Basis zu verbreitern und Franz Josef
strausag kommt überhaupt nicht in Frage
die sind das Problem für uns und wir
müssen diese Wähler wieder
zurückgewinnen und 1950 hat Hans hehard
der damalige Ministerpräsident mit der
SPD eine Koalition gemacht und
1957 nachdem die Vierer Koalition
zerbrochen war hat die CSU nicht mit der
Bayernpartei koaliert was manche wollten
sondern mit der FDP und mit dem BHE und
damit hatte Straus natürlich eine andere
Strategie als die CSU sie in den letzten
Jahren betrieben hat das meine ich das
heißt was ist dann oder was sind die
Freien Wähler dann jetzt für die CSU die
Freien Wähler sind unser Hauptgegner bei
der nächsten Europawahl und bei der
nächsten Bundestagswahl also man sollte
sie nicht mit in die Regierung nehmen
das ging im Moment nicht anders das ist
vertretbar aber die CSU muss immer
wissen wir haben auch eine andere
Alternative
äh und lass uns von den Freien Wählern
nicht erpressen die Grünen standen parat
die FDP ja es wäre sogar mit der
SPD der mit einer Stimme Mehrheit ist
ein bisschen knapp natürlich die Grünen
sind nicht gerade unsere politischen
Freunde das kann ich voll verstehen es
gibt mehr Schnittmengen mit den Freien
Wählern als mit den Grünen aber wenn die
Freien Wähler darauf aussind uns
sozusagen aus dem Bundestag zu kegeln
was bei dem gegenwärtigen Wahlrecht
nicht völlig auszuschließen ist nicht
völlig auszuschließen ist richtig dann
bleibt nichts anderes übrig als einen
harten Abgrenzungskurs zu verfolgen und
klipp und klar zu sagen bei der
Bundestagswahl jede Stimme für die
Freien Wähler ist eine Stimme gegen
Bayern das heißt da muss man einen
massiven emotionalen Wahlkampf machen
und bei der Europawahl und bei der
Europawahl muss man sagen ihr wart
bisher mit einer Abgeordneten im
Europäischen Parlament vertreten glaubt
denn jemand dass die Freien Wähler in
Europa etwas bewegen wenn Sie mit ein
zwei oder drei Leuten emotional sie
sagen sie harter emotionaler Wahlkampf
wenn einer emotional kann dann Hubert
eiwanger ja das können wir auch also so
ist es nicht sondern da muss man mal dem
Hubert eiwanger sagen weißt du
eigentlich wie groß der Export Bayerns
in die anderen EU-Ländern ist es sind
100 Milliarden im Jahr die bayerische
Landwirtschaft 8 Milliarden dieser Herr
eiwanger holt sich vor 10 oder 12 Jahren
den Herrn Henkel einer der einer der
Mitbegründer der AFD und einer ganz
harter eurogegner und skeper und holt
sich den ich habe immer mal gesagt
wissen Sie was für die bayerische
Landwirtschaft es bedeuten würde wenn
die DMark da wä und wir nur eine
Aufwertung von 10% hätten das wä Verlust
von Hunderten von Millionen und wenn ich
in Deutschland äh mir das ansehe wir
haben glaube ich einen Export von über
800 Milliarden Euro in andere Länder 10
% Aufwertung würde bedeuten 80
Milliarden weniger das wä eine
Massenarbeitslosigkeit die in
Deutschland stattfinden würde und mit
solchen Argumenten muss man meines
Achtens dann vorgehen und sagen das war
deine Politik aber warum stellt warum
stellt ich meine es ist doch unfassbar
ironisch um es mal freundlich zu
formulieren das ausgerechnet der
Landwirt Hubert
eiwanger der auch dieses Lied ständig
spielt ich bin da eigentlich an ein
Bauernsohn und so weiter ganz benständig
Jäger so Waldbesitzer genau der ja ein
Landwirt muss doch ein unbedingtes
Interesse daran haben in der EU zu
bleiben ich erinnere mich wir haben vor
ein paar Jahren in England eine
Reportage gedreht und war damals
überrascht dachte er gut auf dem Land
wird man wahrscheinlich Leute treffen
die für den brexit gestimmt haben es war
natürlich ein kompletter Denkfehler auf
dem Land die Bauern haben alle gegen
diesen brexit gestimmt weil die sagten
wo bleiben unsere schönen Subventionen
ohne die Subventionen gehen hier bei uns
die Lichter aus jedes einzelne Schaf
wird irgendwie von der EU subventioniert
und dann wettert dieser Landwirt Hubert
eiwanger der bayerische
Wirtschaftsminister gegen dieses Europa
jedenfalls in der Vergangenheit aber
heute noch den ja und geht durch wird
argumentativ nicht gestellt wir haben
wir haben zu wenig gemacht wir haben das
zu wenig
dargestellt ich habe ihm das mal unter
vier Augen gesagt geredet ja sicher ich
habe ih zufällig in Berlin getroffen
SEAG wie können sie eigentlich als
Agrarier einen solchen Unsinn verzapfen
ja warum hat er das gemacht nur um
Stimme zu gewinnen ich glaube dass er
ganz genau weiß was das für die
bayerische Landwirtschaft bedeutet ich
hätte ja nie meinem Leben gedacht dass
Bayern mal und Deutschland mehr Käse
nach Frankreich exportiert als
Frankreich zu uns so haben sich die
Dinge gewandelt das heißt also ein Segen
früher hat das habe ich ja selber noch
miterlebt jede Aufwertung hat die Bauern
in Deutschland Milliarden gekostet und
wir mussten das aus dem Bundeshaushalt
einigermaßen ausgleichen und das ist weg
seidem se eine gemeinsame Währung geht
die Bau gibt die Bauern können
kalkulieren und verlieren durch eine
solche aufwert nicht mehr Geld so völlig
unverständlich das heißt genauso wie
beim Impfen hat sich nur überlegt wo
gewinne ich noch mal ein paar Prozent
für meine Freien Wähler und für meinen
Siegeszug in der Politik wird ja auch
noch ein bisschen ironischer wenn man
sich mal klar macht da redet der
bayerische Wirtschaftsminister dass
jemand dem die Wirtschaft Bayerns sehr
am Herzen liegen müsste wettert aber
gegen Stromtrassen ja es geht um Energie
für sein Land es geht um energ für
Bayern ja das ist richtig da gab's
natürlich auch ein paar in der CSU die
also nicht so ganz intensiv für die
notwendigen stromdassen
warof mir fällt mir fällt im Moment kein
Name ein aber sie haben Recht nicht auch
das ist ein Punkt da muss man dann
wenigstens zugeben okay da habe ich mich
damals geirrt nicht oder denken Sie an
das Impfen er macht mit in der
bayerischen Staatsregierung wenn eine
Impfkampagne gemacht wird um also diese
furchtbare Krankheit in den Griff zu
bekommen und dann sagt er aber ich ich
lasse mich nicht impfen weil er genau
weiß es gibt auch 10 15% in Bayern die
Impfgegner sind gerade in den Regionen
wo er herum wildert nicht W und nutzt
auch das aus und das ist das ist
Populismus den man entzaubern muss den
man entlarfen muss und den man ihm auf
die Dauer nicht durchgehen lassen darf
wie fanden sie in dem Zusammenhang den
Auftritt in Erding
der war schlimm der war schlimm der
Markus Söder hat sich hingestellt und
hat sich da auch ganz klar abgegrenzt
und hat dafür nicht nur Beifall geertet
dann zu sagen also die da oben haben den
Arsch offen ist schon ein bisschen
unapetitliche Formulierung so vier Tage
oder 5 Tage später und wir müssen uns
die Demokratie zurück zurückholen da
komme ich gleich aber 4 f Tage später
ist eine Wirtschaftsminister Konferenz
und er stellt sich neben habeg den er
direkt gemeint hat hin und macht wieder
ein gemeinsames Bild nach dem Motto was
schert mich mein dummes Geschwätz vor
vor vier Tagen sich die Demokratie
zurückholen ist nichts anderes als was
gauland in einer schlimmen Art und Weise
dargestellt hat und dann noch zu sagen
bei Ihnen das sei nur eine formale
Demokratie das ist schon bodenlos wie
fanden sie das ich fand das bodenlos et
war eine eine Ausrede eine reine Ausrede
weil er dann plötzlich merkt hoppla
überall kann ich mit den unsäglichen
Platitüden die ich
bei Volksfesten und sonst wo von sich
geben kann mit denen komme ich sonst
nicht mehr
durch und in dem Zusammenhang das
Flugblatt was haben Sie gedacht
als sie davon gehört
haben das Flugblatt ist das eine der
Umgang mit dem Flugblatt das andere
also zunächst ich erinnere mich ziemlich
genau an Dummheiten die ich mit 17 oder
18 Jahren gemacht habe ich habe auch
Dummheiten
gemacht eine war z.B wenn es um
Imitation geht ich habe gern Leute
imitiert auch später Politiker das haben
die mir manchmal nicht verziehen auch
Strauß und höcher und ähnliche mehr
Ludwig Huber und ich kann mich erinnern
da war mal eine ganz fade Veranstaltung
Schulveranstaltung und dann sagt ja
einer damit es ein bisschen Lust wird
kannst du nicht unseren Lateinlehrer
nachmachen das habe ich dann gemacht
großes Gaudium ein halbes Jahr später
bekam ich im betragen die mindeste Note
weil sich das nicht zieht also kann mich
sehr genau daran erinnern wenn Hubert ge
wenn ubert eiwanger gesagt hätte also da
ist damals was dummes passiert ich
wollte mein Bruder schützen ich wollte
meinen Eltern Ärger ersparen und habe
deswegen das auf mich genommen tut mir
heute Leid dann wäre die ganze
Geschichte selbstverständlich erledigt
gewesen und jeder hätte gesagt okay
jeder von uns hat auch mal Blödsinn
gemacht das ganze ist das Ganze ist
erledigt aber das in Schüben zu machen
je nachdem was wann
dann an die Öffentlichkeit gelangt ist
und dann noch mit sehr starken
Gedächtnislücken zu arbeiten wobei er ja
alle reden auch im bayerischen tag und
sonst wo frei hält und wer frei redet
hat meistens ein gutes Gedächtnis das
ist etwas was den Umgang mit dem ganzen
für sehr problematisch hält und tja dass
man damit 4% Zuwachs bekommt indem man
sich plötzlich als Opfer stilisiert das
ist eine bittere Erkenntnis aber auf die
Dauer wird auch so etwas nicht anhalten
auch da wachsen die Bäume nicht in den
Himmel was haben Sie Markus Süder
geraten in dem
Zusammenhang ich habe ihm gesagt lass
dich nicht
erpressen und ich bin überzeugt dass er
das auch selber so sieht und sich nichts
mehr gefallen lässt so wie er es gemacht
hat das glaube ich war der richtige
Umgang et war ihm die Fragen zu
stellen er hat sich entschuldigt okay
hat das versucht auch mit den jüdischen
Gemeinden zu machen das muss man
akzeptieren aber ich bin ganz sicher
dass die Liebe zwischen den beiden stark
abgekühlt ist